Dean returns to paradise for Kaitlyn I
knew that I needed to come here and tell
you that I wanted us to try and be in a
relationship and that's at the end of
the day the biggest thing mustache list
Dean returned to the beach on Tuesday
night's episode of bachelor in paradise
Dean is back I have no idea what this
days about to do but here he is with no
mustache Dean means business just as
things seem to be winding down and
couples were settling in the 28 year old
shook things up again by going back to
Paradise in hopes of winning Kaitlyn
back I just
wanna partner in life
and I don't think it's just taking a
little bit longer to realize that let's
rewind Deena left paradise and kalynn a
few weeks back on her birthday right
after giving her a rose
keeping her in Paradise on the night of
the rose ceremony when I left I made a
decision that I thought was best for you
but it wasn't really fair of me to make
that decision and just before bachelor
alums crystal Nielson and Chris ran
Dawn's wedding you'll see Kaitlyn come
to the wedding and Dean just left her
and so now she's alone she's sulking and
imagine having to be like we have to go
to a wedding and celebrate love I think
that's the last thing completely
heartbroken although she was heartbroken
over Dean Kalyn got close with newcomer
Connor while he was away are you guys
gonna go
[Music]
once easy Kaelin clearly still has
feelings for Dean but will she leave
paradise for him I know it's like a big
heavy thing
but I came here to ask you if that you
would leave paradise with me today
or cozy back up with Connor we've had an
amazing connection so far I don't want
that to end and especially over this
loser I'll have to stay tuned if it does
happen great but if not then I'm not
willing to you know fight it